>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Sasha Dowdy: Welcome
Tyler Elementary School.
It's so good to have you guys.
So, welcome to the Library of
Congress, Young Readers Center.
We have two really awesome
guests for you today.
So, the first person is on my right.
He is Illustrator, Brian Biggs,
and he collaborated on this book,
"Noisy Night", and you might know
him for a series of book called,
"Everything Goes" and "Tinyville."
And, on my left we have Author, Mac
Barnett and he has written a lot
of books that you might have heard
of as well, such as "Extra Yarn"
or maybe you know "Leo,
A ghost story"
and I'm sure every single public
library in school library has books
by these awesome in individuals.
So, without further ado, I just want
to introduce and welcome
our authors.
So, everybody say,
welcome [welcome].
>> Brian Biggs: Ah, thank you.
Thank you.
>> Mac Barnett: Yeah, absolutely.
How about a huge round of
applause for us [applause]?
>> Brian Biggs: Yes.
>> Mac Barnett: Oh,
please, please, please.
No, please, more applause,
please, please [applause].
Ah, that feels good.
Oh, we're going to need
that for the walk home.
Good morning.
How are you?
>> Classroom: Good.
>> Mac Barnett: My
name is Mac Barnett.
>> Brian Biggs: My
name is Brian Biggs.
>> Mac Barnett: I'm an author.
>> Brian Biggs: I'm an illustrator.
>> Mac Barnett: What's my job?
What does that mean
if I'm an author?
Yeah, what does an author do?
>> Student: He writes down books.
>> Mac Barnett: That's
exactly right.
I write books.
Yeah, how about an illustrator?
What does an illustrator do?
>> Brian Biggs: Does anybody
know what an illustrator does?
>> Mac Barnett: Yeah?
>> Student: Writes pictures.
>> Mac Barnett: Yaay.
>> Brian Biggs: Writes the pictures.
>> Mac Barnett: That's
exactly right.
So, Brian is actually
an author/illustrator.
He's really good at
writing words and pictures,
so sometimes he makes his books and
he puts the pictures inside them,
and puts the words inside them,
and he does it all himself.
Me, I'm just an author.
I'm not very good at
drawing pictures at all.
But, luckily, I have friends,
like Brian, so when I write a book
and need some pictures Brian and I
can work together and make the book.
So, this is actually a book we
just made called, "Noisy Night."
This book is so new, it just
came out three days ago.
That was the first day that you
could find this book at a library.
That was the first day that
you could find this book
at a book store.
That was, what is known in
the publishing business,
as this books "book Birthday"
and I know what you're thinking.
I didn't buy your book a
Birthday present [laughter].
I didn't send your
book a Birthday card.
I never even sang happy
Birthday to your book.
>> Brian Biggs: No.
Oh, my goodness.
>> Mac Barnett: I know, I know.
And, our book knows too, trust me.
We were driving over
here this morning
and we were listening to the radio.
It was fun.
We were having some good music on.
I like to listen to the radio
really loud when I drive,
and our book was like, "Hey,
Brian and Mac, hey Brian and Mac,
can I turn down the radio?"
We talk to our books
sometimes, it's not crazy.
And, our book was like, "Hey
Brian and Mac, where we going?"
I said, the Library of Congress.
The book was like,
"That's really exciting.
Who are we going to see there?"
I was like, we are going to see
the kids from Tyler Elementary.
Yeah, that was exciting for me, our
book though did not say whoo whoo,
our book was like,
"Tyler Elementary, pshhh."
[laughter].
Those are the kids who forgot about
my Birthday, and it was awkward.
>> Brian Biggs: It was awkward.
>> Mac Barnett: But,
we can fix this.
Now, I don't know if you've
ever sung happy Birthday
to a book before, but you don't just
get to say happy Birthday dear book.
No, you have to say
the books full title.
Happy Birthday dear Noisy Nights,
written by Mac Barnett [laughter]
and illustrated by Brian Biggs.
Published by Roaring Brook,
an imprint of MacMillan,
copyright 2017.
>> Brian Biggs: That's it.
>> Mac Barnett: That was a lot.
I know that was a lot.
I know that was alot.
So, we're going to
practice that once through.
So, listen carefully and then repeat
back what I just said, alright?
Ready? Happy Birthday Dear Noisy
Nights, written by Mac Barnett
and illustrated by Brian Biggs,
published by Roaring
Brook, copyright 2017.
One, two, three.
Everybody say that.
>> Class: One, two.
Happy Birthday.
>> Mac Barnett: Ha, ha.
That was a good try.
Birthday, alright.
>> Brian Biggs: That was good.
>> Mac Barnett: I think
we got it [clapping].
Perfect. Alright, alright.
We're warmed up, ready to go.
I don't know what could go wrong.
>> Brian Biggs: Nothing.
>> Mac Barnett: Let's
warm up our voices.
Everybody give me this
note [humming].
[ Humming Sounds ]
>> Mac Barnett: Beautiful,
beautiful.
Now, if I could get this note
from you [high humming sound].
[ High Humming Sounds ]
>> Mac Barnett: That
was pretty good.
I don't know if either
of those notes are
in the song, but that was cool.
That was cool [laughter].
Alright, our voices are warmed up.
Let's sing happy Birthday,
to this book.
One, two, three.
>> Everybody: Happy Birthday to you.
>> Brian Biggs: Come on sing.
Everybody.
>> Everybody: Happy Birthday to you.
Happy Birthday Dear Noisy
Night, written by Mac Barnett,
and illustrated by Brian Biggs,
published by Roaring Brook,
and MacMillan, copyright 2017.
>> Mac Barnett: That's it.
>> Everybody: Happy Birthday to you.
>> Mac Barnett: Whew.
Ah, how beautiful [clapping].
That was a beautiful moment.
Alright, I'm feeling good.
Are you feeling good Brian?
>> Brian Biggs: I already
think, yeah.
>> Mac Barnett: The
book's feeling good.
Let's do this.
Here we go.
Noisy Nights.
You can see here, is
a kid, asleep, in bed.
Noisy Night.
Written by, me.
Illustrated by.
>> Brian Biggs: Me.
>> Mac Barnett: The kid says, "What
is going la la la above my head?"
Yeah, what do you think
is making that noise?
What do you think is
going, la la la?
Yeah, what do you think?
>> Student: People
stomping on the roof.
>> Mac Barnett: People
stomping around the roof?
Let's see, let's see.
That's a good guess.
That's what happens at
my house all the time.
I'll tell you that.
A man is singing opera above my
head, and he says, "La, la, laaaa."
Can you do that for me?
One, two, three.
>> Classroom: La, la, laaa.
>> Mac Barnett: Nice.
Yeah, are you classically trained?
That was amazing.
>> Brian Biggs: That's the best yet.
>> Mac Barnett: That was amazing.
And, now the opera man
says, "What is going,
ma ma ma ma above my head?"
What do you think is going
ma ma ma above his head?
What do you think is
making that noise?
Who would make a noise like that?
Does anyone have a guess?
What do you think?
Yeah?
>> Student: Maybe a scooter.
>> Mac Barnett: Oh, a scooter.
Yeah, because we have some wheels.
Yeah right?
It could be a scooter.
Let's see.
A baby, is cooing above my head,
and the baby says, "Ma, ma, ma."
[laughter].
Can you do that [laughter]?
Yeah, let's do it all at once.
One, two, three.
>> Classroom: Ma, ma, ma.
>> Mac Barnett: That's good.
You guys sound like
a bunch of babies.
That's amazing.
That was amazing.
And, now the baby says, "What is
going ba ba ba above my head?"
What do you think it is?
What's going ba ba ba?
A sheep.
>> Brian Biggs: What?
>> Mac Barnett: This is
an apartment building.
>> Brian Biggs: That
doesn't make any sense.
>> Mac Barnett: A sheep living
in an apartment building?
I don't think so.
That's just crazy.
It's a sheep.
You were right.
>> Brian Biggs: Get a
little fist pump there.
>> Mac Barnett: A sheep
is speaking above my head,
and the sheep goes,
"Maa, maa, maaa."
[laughter].
Let's do that.
One, two, three.
>> Classroom: Maa, maa, maa.
>> Mac Barnett: That's good,
that's good, that's good.
And now, the sheep says, "What is
going on ha ha ha above my head?"
What would make that noise?
Ha, ha, ha.
We have a little clue there.
What do you think?
>> Student: It's a cowboy.
>> Mac Burnett: Cowboy.
Let's see [class chatter].
>> Brian Biggs: Cowboy.
>> Mac Barnett: Cowboys
are laughing above my head.
And, they go, hah hah hah.
Can we do that?
One, two, three.
>> Classroom: Hah hah hah
>> Mac Barnett: That's good.
And, they say, "What is going
wah wah wah above our heads?"
[classroom chatter].
What would make that noise?
What would do that?
Anybody have a guess?
Here's the picture.
What do you think?
>> Student: A girl.
>> Mac Barnett: A girl.
Let's see.
A girl is playing trumpet
above our head.
>> Brian Biggs: Nice work.
>> Mac Barnett: You got it.
Yeah, and the trumpet goes,
wah wah wah [laughter].
Let's do that.
One, two, three.
>> Classroom: Wah, wah, wah.
>> Mac Barnett: Nice, yeah.
And, the girls say, "What is
going caw caw caw above my head?"
You have a guess?
>> Student: A crow.
>> Mac Barnet: A crow.
A crow is squawking above my head.
And, the crow goes, caw caw caw.
Let's do that.
One, two, three.
>> Classroom: Caw, caw, caw.
>> Mac Barnett: Fantastic.
And, now the crow says, "What is
going rah rah rah above my head?"
[classroom chatter].
What do we think?
What is going rah rah rah?
Any guesses?
Yeah? Do you have a guess?
>> Student: Rah, rah, rah.
Maybe it's just a man
with funny shoes.
>> Mac Barnett: Maybe it's
just a man with funny shoes.
That looks like a good guess to me.
Let's see.
Cheerleaders, are cheering above my
head, and they say, "Rah, rah, rah."
Let's do that.
One, two, three.
>> Everybody: Rah, rah, rah.
>> Mac Barnett: There they are.
And, they say, "What is going
cha, cha, cha above our heads?
What is going cha, cha, cha?
>> Student: The dancers.
>> Mac Barnett: Dancers.
A couple is dancing above our
heads, and it goes cha, cha, cha.
Let's do that.
One, two, three.
>> Everybody: Cha, cha, cha, cha.
>> Mac Barnett: Ah, that was good.
>> Brian Biggs: Yeah.
>> Mac Barnett: That was
smooth [classroom chatter].
And, they say, "What is going
blah, blah, blah above our heads?"
What do you think [inaudible
comment]?
Let's see.
An old man is hollering,
"Go to bed."
Let's all try to holler
that at once.
One, two, three.
>> Everyone: Go to bed.
>> Mac Barnett: Click.
The lights all turn off below him,
and then he turns off the light.
>> Student: What?
>> Mac Barnett: And, he goes to bed.
And, that is the end
-- of Noisy Nights.
>> Brian Biggs: Yeah.
>> Mac Barnett: Give yourself a big
round of applause for those noises.
Oh, you guys.
>> Brian Biggs: Yeah, those
sound effects were good.
>> Mac Barnett: That's fantastic.
Brian, can you show us a little bit
about how you made
all those pictures?
>> Brian Biggs: I would love
to show you a little bit
about how I made those,
what were they?
>> Mac Barnett: Great pictures.
>> Brian Biggs: Great pictures.
Thank you, Mac.
Hey, guys, does anybody
here like to draw?
Nobody likes to draw?
Not a single person in this
room likes -- you like to draw?
Give me five on that one.
Alright, because I like to draw.
[ Classroom Chatter ]
>> Brian Biggs: Ooops.
So, this is an amazing,
behind the scenes look
at how I illustrated Noisy
Night, by Brian Biggs.
So, I like to think that
authors actually draw.
You know, they sit around and they
draw and they think of good ideas
for books, and then they
write the words with them.
But, what I always
see is just the words.
So, you guys -- the
authors write the story,
and in this case the sound effects
as well, and then the illustrator,
me, I put the words for
the pictures to the words.
So, here. Oh, I'm going to
show you first some other books
I've illustrated.
I forget the order of
this thing sometimes.
It's gotten carried
away as well, the --
we're going to try to do this again.
Alright, stay there this time.
Alright. So, these are
the books I illustrated.
Some of them I wrote as well.
Here are some books
I did not illustrate.
These were written by Mac,
and they were illustrated
by other fine illustrators,
Jon Klassen.
Jon Klassen, Christian
Robinson, Matt Myers.
So, this was what I saw.
This was the book the way it
existed before I illustrated it.
>> Mac Barnett: Look at that.
That's the whole book.
>> Brian Biggs: That's the
whole book right there.
So, my favorite part about
it was this part right here.
I focused on what words I really
liked, and that was it right there.
The word noisy.
You guys like the word noisy?
>> Student: Yes.
>> Brian Biggs: When I
first saw this manuscript,
I was really afraid it was going
to be called something like,
"Quiet Night" or "Really
Silent People
in an Apartment Building Night."
But, instead it was
called, "Noisy Night"
and it got me really
excited about that.
And, I thought about it and I said,
how can I illustrate
the word "noisy?"
So, I started thinking about how I
would do that, and we have wah, wah,
wah, and la la la, and that
was the first thing I thought
about with the cha, cha, cha, and
ma, ma, ma, and caw, caw, caw,
and ha, ha ha, and I don't
remember all the other.
>> Mac Barnett: Blah, blah, blah.
>> Brian Biggs: Yep, there ya go.
>> Student: Baa, baa, baa.
>> Brian Biggs: Yep.
I memorized the book already.
Now, I could see [inaudible].
So, this is some of the sketches I
did for some of the sound effects.
You can see the caw caw caw, the wah
wah wah, and this is on just pieces
of paper with a pen or a pencil,
and that's the way I start
thinking about a book a first.
It's just what's kind
of my favorite parts
about it, drawing little sketches.
You guys know what a sketch is?
Anybody thought about a sketch?
What's a sketch?
You?
>> Student: A sketch is kind of like
a -- writing with a pen or a pencil.
>> Brian Biggs: Yeah.
I think you're exactly right.
It's like practice drawing.
So, before I make the
final paintings
for the book I do a little practice
drawings with a pen or a pencil.
You're exactly right.
>> Mac Barnett: Something I like
about these, I think is so cool is,
you made these words
look like they sound.
>> Brian Biggs: That's important.
You're right.
Speaking of sounds and.
Yeah, can everyone please
turn off your cell phones,
including the author [laughter].
Thank you very much.
You can see, like there's
a ha ha in the far right,
because it's very different
from the way it ended up being.
And, so that's actually
really a good point.
I started thinking about what
does the word la la la look like.
So, this is the la la
la in a sketch here,
when really it turned
out very different.
The way the caw looked was very --
was right on from the
very beginning,
and so that was really
interesting to me.
And, so here's the la la
la the way it turned out.
Here's some of the text.
A girl is playing trumpet
above our heads.
It looks like cowboy type.
So, cowboys were talking.
It just comes from, maybe old
posters I've seen or if you go
to a western saloon, I'm sure you've
all been to western saloons a lot,
you can see that kind
of type on the menu.
So, I'm going to show
you some sketches.
That's what the sketches are.
These are the practice drawings,
and what you're going to see is,
this is a sketch of the cha cha
dancers, how they looked at first.
I have a mirror in my studio, and
the way I get my ideas is I dance
in front of the mirror and
then I draw what I see.
I'm a really, really fine cha
cha dancer too [laughter].
I'm not going to show you.
You're all just going
to have to believe me.
So, here's some sketches
of a cha cha dancer.
And, then this is how the
finished drawing looks here.
So, you can see it's
a little different.
But, for the most part it's
kind of pretty close, right?
Oops, there's my opera singer there.
Some pencil drawings with the la la.
Here's another sketch there.
And, then we go to
the finished drawing.
Ooops. Come on.
Technology.
This is the finished drawing here.
It's a black and white drawing,
on paper, and then it goes
in to the computer and gets
colored in the computer here,
and these are the finished
pages there.
So, here's some cowboys.
You guys ever draw cowboys?
Does anybody ever -- .
What's the most important
part of a cowboy to draw,
you think [background comments]?
The hat? You like cowboy hats?
Do you guys have a cowboy hat?
>> Mac Barnett: What'd you think?
What was the most important part?
>> Student: Cowboy hat.
>> Brian Biggs: Cowboy hat.
>> Mac Barnett: Yep,
she's just saying that.
Okay, I'm going to go
with it [laughter].
>> Brian Biggs: More cowboys.
Sometimes cowboys have
big glasses, right?
Do you think cowboys
might have big glasses on?
They think something's really funny.
This was my favorite stuff to
draw, because it was the idea
that something is so
funny, and you have --
the best part, it wasn't just
one cowboy, like we had one crow.
We had one trumpet player, but
he had cowboys in the text,
and cheerleaders in the
text, so it was plural
and I really liked the
idea of having two cowboys,
and it's the idea that they
just hold a good joke, you know,
and we get them just as
the joke has been told
and they think it's really funny.
In fact, why did you have not
just cheerleader and cowboy,
but you had two plurals there?
I was curious.
>> Mac Barnett: Why do I
do the things I do, Brian?
>> Brian Biggs: That's a good
answer Mac [background chatter].
Thanks for that illuminating
reply [laughter].
Now, you may be surprised that
over the three or four years
since we started this
book I've never asked him
that question before,
but it's just never --
we don't talk about the
book as I'm doing it,
and it hasn't come
up until just now.
So, here's a sketch for
that with four cowboys
and we ended up just doing the two.
It just doesn't like
to stay on one slide.
There we go.
>> Students: Eww, eww.
>> Brian Biggs: And,
then here's the crows.
You guys ever seen
a crow with a hat?
>> Students: No.
>> Brian Biggs: Well, Mac didn't
write that the crow has a hat,
but in my imagination
crows have hats [laughter].
I think it's important that you
give the crow a nice little hat.
So, there he was.
His feather fell off.
He's pretty upset about it.
And, then here's the
baby [classroom chatter].
And, there's the two babies
in the book [chatter].
So, the cover's the
most important part.
Does anybody here judge
a book by its cover?
Has anybody done that before?
You walk in to the book
store and you see two books
about Theodore Roosevelt, and one
of them has a really ugly cover
and one's an amazing cover.
We are probably going to get
the amazing cover one, right?
That's what I'd do, at least.
That's how I buy my
records, in fact.
So, this is the cover of
the book and I knew I had
to make it something that was
like really gets your attention.
So, it was going to have a building.
It takes place in an
apartment building.
This is the most important
part of the text,
is the part that you
guys didn't see.
The action takes place in an
apartment building in the city.
What you don't see is, with a sheep
in it, but there was a sheep in it.
So, we have a couple
of tall buildings.
These old apartment buildings,
and I love the way they look.
I'm a big fan of cities.
I'm a big fan of the way buildings
look, and the way cities work,
and streets and that sort of thing.
So, I also like these old neon
lights that go top of buildings.
This is one here on
Brooklynn, on the right,
that I took from the subway.
They just pulled that Kent Tile
floor sign down a couple of --
about a year ago or so, very sad.
So, you have the hotel signs
here, and putting it together,
that's kind of the way I
thought this would look,
the cover would look,
is this building
with a big neon light on top.
So, there's some sketches with that.
Noisy Night, noisy night,
and just trying to think --
even those these almost
all look exactly the same,
you can see the difference
in the windows,
the difference in the angles.
Is it a light background
with a dark building,
or a dark background
with a light building?
And, there's a lot of
different choices I had
in putting this together.
So, here's a good sketch
that we ended up liking,
had to have all the
stories in the thing.
And, then this is a picture I took
about 12 years ago in New York City,
and this is kind of
the mood that I wanted.
It's a photo I took from, actually
from the Workman Publishing office
in lower Manhattan, and that feel,
that kind of almost nighttime feel
is exactly what I was trying to go
for with the coloring, and so that's
kind of what we ended up with there.
And, it's important if you look
at the bottom you'll
see the boy yelling up,
then you see the upper man with the
purple, and then you see the baby
in the green, the sheep,
the cowboys, the trumpet,
and you have a crow, and
you have cheerleaders.
You have cha cha dancers, and
then you have the old man,
and do you guys remember
what the old man is saying?
>> Students: Go to bed.
>> Brian Biggs: Go to bed.
There he is right there.
So, thank you very much you guys.
I appreciate it.
Alright.
[ Applause ]
>> Mac Barnett: Now, we have
something else we want to show you,
but before we do that we
just want to make sure
that we answered any questions
you had about this book,
about being an author,
or being an illustrator,
about making books, about anything.
If you have a question, ask it
and we will try to answer it.
Yes?
>> Jill: I'm going to come
out with a microphone.
>> Student: Why did you
feel like being an author.
>> Mac Barnett: Good.
Why did I feel like being an author?
Three reasons.
I love reading books.
I love telling stories, and I love
sleeping in really late [laughter].
And, authors get to do
all three of those things.
I read books every day.
That's the best way to get
better at writing is to read.
I get to tell stories, not just
to people who can hear my voice,
but to people across the world.
I live in California, but you know,
you over here in Washington
D.C could read one of my books.
That's crazy.
And then, I get to wake
up whenever I want to.
That's even crazier.
>> Brian Biggs: Yeah.
>> Mac Barnett: That's
the best, yeah.
Who else has a question.
>> Brian Biggs: Jill, you wanted to
get the microphone in front of them?
>> Jill: Oh yeah, so if
anyone has a question I can.
>> Mac Barnett: We have
a question back there.
>> Jill: Okay.
>> Student: What about
when you cross the street?
Will you hold hands?
>> Mac Barnett: That's
a good question.
When we cross the street
do we hold hands?
Yeah, Brian and I did, right?
We were at the capitol a little bit
before this, and then we came over
and held hands crossing the street.
It's very safe.
It's the way to do it.
>> Jill: Do you have a question?
>> Student: Yes [background noise].
But, why do you don't write words?
>> Mac Barnett: Oh, why?
>> Brian Biggs: That question again.
>> Mac Barnett: So, I do write
words, but I don't do pictures.
And, the reason for that is, when I
draw pictures they're not very good.
I would love it if my pictures
could come out in a book.
In fact, I have one book where
I did get to draw some pictures,
because in the middle of the
book I fired the illustrator.
>> Brian Biggs: That's right.
>> Mac Barnett: And, I said, I'm
taking this book over myself.
This book needs a true genious, me.
And, then I draw all the pictures,
and all the pictures are really bad,
so I have to re-hire the
illustrator, and rescue him
from lion's belly, because I
also made him get swallowed
by a lion in that story too.
I'm not a great guy.
Who else has a question?
>> Student: Why do you --
write books the wrong way?
[ Laughter ]
>> Brian Biggs: You
must be talking to me,
because Mac doesn't write
books the wrong way.
What.
>> Mac Barnett: You know what?
Writing books the wrong way.
>> Brian Biggs: I wanted
to illumate that question.
>> Mac Barnett: Writing books
the wrong way is always a part
of writing books.
That's the first time you write a
book, there's always something wrong
with it, and you go back and you
try to fix all the things again,
and again, and you go
back and you rewrite it,
and there are still things wrong
with it, and you rewrite it,
until finally you say,
this is really good
and then you put the
book out and even then,
you'll usually find
something wrong with it.
But, they've already
printed thousands of copies.
And, it's okay, you just say I'll
try to do better the next time.
>> Brian Biggs: You
got to do it again.
>> Mac Barnett: There will always
be something wrong with it.
I don't think I'll ever
write a perfect book.
But, that's alright.
I'll try to keep getting better.
>> Brian Biggs: That
was a good answer.
>> Student: I really like the book,
because it's so funny [clapping].
>> Mac Barnett: Yeah,
that's a good question.
That's good.
I like that.
Let's end with that.
End strong.
Thank you.
You know what, I'll show you a
little bit about writing this book.
>> Brian Biggs: Yep.
>> Mac Barnett: So,
it's called Noisy Night,
and it's about a noisy
apartment building,
and when I wrote this book I lived
in a noisy apartment building,
heard noises all through the night,
and so I said, I'm going to write
about my favorite subjects.
Me. So, I was like,
what's a good noise?
What's a good noise?
And, I sat down and I was thinking
of a good noise and I started right
at the beginning here
[drawing], and what's that?
>> Student: A.
>> Mac Barnett: A. The letter
A. I said, that's a good noise.
It's got that ahh sound.
Let's all hear it?
Ahh.
>> Everyone: Ahh,
>> Mac Barnett: Yeah, so I moved on.
I was like alright we're
off to a good start.
Where we going next?
[ Classroom Chatter ]
B. Perfect.
Best place to go next, ba.
Ba ba ba. What would
make that noise?
The sheep.
That's exactly right.
A sheep. I was like, now I
got a character in this book.
This is great.
>> Student: Now the C.
>> Mac Barnett: C,
you're in fact right.
That's where I went next.
>> Brian Biggs: She's a good writer.
>> Student: Caw.
>> Mac Barnett: Caw, caw, caw.
That's the crow.
That's right.
I said, I'm on a roll.
This thing is firing.
Then, I went to D.
>> Student: Dah, dah, dah.
>> Mac Barnett: Dah, dah, dah.
I couldn't think of
anything for that one.
anything to go dah dah dah.
So, can you help me out?
Can you think of something that
would make that dah dah dah sound?
Yeah, what do you think?
>> Student: Dah dah
dah, what is up there?
>> Mac Barnett: What is up there?
What is up there making that
dah dah dah, so that's good.
That would be the page
before, right?
>> Brian Biggs: That's
the page before.
>> Mac Barnett: Maybe the
sheep and the sheep is saying,
dah dah dah, what is up there?
And, then you turn the page
and you find somebody making
or something going dah dah dah.
>> Brian Biggs: What would it be?
>> Mac Barnett: What
would make that noise?
Can you think of anything?
>> Student: The old man.
>> Mac Barnett: An old man.
Yeah, that's right.
>> Brian Biggs: We haven't
drawn an old man ending.
An alternate ending.
>> Mac Barnett: This is going
to be the alternate ending.
>> Brian Biggs: It's going
to be a different old man.
>> Mac Barnett: So, you're
going to draw an old man?
>> Brian Biggs: There's two
old me living in this house.
>> Mac Barnett: Alright.
Here we go.
>> Brian Biggs: One looks like
Santa Claus and one won't.
>> Mac Barnett: Right now,
do you want to see Brian draw
on the spot, a new ending?
Alright, let's do it.
>> Brian Biggs: This is my
powerful Crayola marker.
Crayola, registered
trademark marker.
I have to give it credit
where credit's due.
This chair is in my way.
Oops, I didn't mean to
step on your water there.
I hope it's okay.
Alright, so as a trained
professional illustrator I have lots
of shapes that I draw.
I have lots of ways to get
started with a drawing.
I know secrets that you may not know
about how to start an illustration.
This is going to be amazing.
Is everybody ready?
It's going to be an
old man and we're going
to have to start somewhere.
Watch this.
[ Student Comments ]
It's pretty good, right?
Does anybody know what
this shape is?
Yes sir?
>> Student: Circle.
>> Brian Biggs: Wrong.
Does anybody know what this shape
-- use your imagination, is?
Yes ma'am?
>> Student: A sphere.
>> Brian Biggs: It's a what?
>> Brian Biggs: A sphere?
No. One more.
Yes?
>> Student: A circle.
>> Brian Biggs: It's --
okay, it is a circle now.
We have changed it,
because I cannot argue
with children any longer
than three times.
I have teenagers.
They can argue all day.
These guys, I'm not going to do.
But, I like to think of
this as, it's a head.
So, you see what I mean?
So, if I draw this, for instance,
does anybody know what this is?
>> Student: An o.
>> Brian Biggs: Yes?
>> Brian Biggs: That's a
better answer than a circle.
But, I'm going to give you
one more hint with this.
It's getting complicated now.
How about that [inaudible comment]?
Okay, I'm going to
give you one more hint.
>> Mac Barnett: Great.
I think I heard it [laughter].
>> Brian Biggs: Alright, is anybody
starting to recognize it now?
>> Mac Barnett: Yes, go for it.
>> Brian Biggs: Yes?
>> Mac Barnett: Go for it.
>> Student: It's an arm.
>> Brian Biggs: No.
>> Mac Barnett: I think
we have it back here.
>> Student: It's a pancake.
>> Brian Biggs: It's
a donut [laughter].
Come on. I'm a pro.
I've won awards.
I'm a New York Times
Best-Selling illustrator.
Alright, so we're going to start
getting a little crazy here.
This is where it gets tough.
He's -- This is.
Now, you might think this is
just a backwards letter C,
but it's not [classroom comments].
This old man's doing something.
Alright, alright, alright.
He's excited about
this, what was it again?
>> Student: A donut.
>> Brian Biggs: Yeah, he's excited
about this donut [background
comments].
Oh my gosh, circle.
Alright, so old men have
thick glasses, right?
[ Classroom Chatter ]
I know one who does.
Yeah. I'm going to take this
opportunity to tell everybody
that yesterday was my Birthday,
and I turned 49 years old
and so I think I fit in to
the old man category now.
And, my daughter, last night pointed
out that even my moustache
was starting to turn gray.
So, this morning I almost shaved
it off before I left the house.
Alright, so here's this.
Mac, you didn't know it was my
Birthday, yesterday did you?
>> Mac Barnett: No, you
never mentioned it before.
>> Brian Biggs: Never
mentioned it yesterday.
Alright, so old men also have a
lot of wrinkles on their faces,
and they have these big
moustaches here, and it's going
to have scribbles in it here,
and they've got no hair,
so I'm not that old, because
I've got lots of hair.
And, then they wear ties.
Okay? Ties.
Okay, so this old man, and
what was the word again?
Anybody remember?
I think the word was da da da.
Yeah, ah, he wants a donut.
[ Classroom Chatter ]
I forgot what the second
word was [chatter].
>> Sasha Dowdy: What
was the next word?
>> Student: Da.
>> Brian Biggs: Da [chatter].
Am I spelling it correctly?
What was the third word?
>> Student: Da [laughter].
>> Brian Biggs: Okay, I believe you.
and, then the second most important
part of the Noisy Night drawings is,
you have to have this shape
here that points to his head,
so that you know who's saying it,
and that is called
the "voice balloon."
It's a technical term.
You may have never heard it before.
We're trained in college to
know what these things are.
So, there's our old man yelling, da
da da, because he wants that donut,
and he's obviously missing an arm.
I cannot believe this.
>> Mac Barnett: How about
a big round of applause?
>> Brian Biggs: Thank you.
>> Mac Barnett: For Brian Biggs
[thank you] for drawing on the spot.
>> Brian Biggs: Thank
you [applause].
>> Mac Barnett: And, how about
an even huger round of applause
for me, for just sitting there.
>> Brian Biggs: Yeah.
>> Mac Barnett: Thank
you, thank you, thank you.
Now, before we go I want to
show you something kind of cool.
I've never seen this
before in my life.
Something that you can really --
it was made here, and
maybe can only see here.
This is a book I wrote called, "The
Skunk" but, it's a special version
that got made here, I
know, it's a little gross.
Yeah. It's about a man who gets
followed around by a skunk.
But, inside of this book has
something that's very cool.
This book is a braille
edition of the book.
>> Brian Biggs: Wow.
>> Mac Barnett: Does
anybody know what Braille is?
>> Brian Riggs: That's pretty cool.
>> Mac Barnett: Braille
is an alphabet
that you -- yeah, did you know?
Yeah?
>> Student: Yes.
If you -- - [inaudible comment].
>> Mac Barnett: This is different.
This one is just me and
somebody named Patrick MacDonald.
So, Brian is just going to sit
here while I talk about this.
So, this book is in braille,
and braille is an alphabet
that you can feel instead of see.
So, if you can't see you could still
read the book just by feeling it.
So, if you touch this right here,
you can feel the cover and this,
in braille, says, "The Skunk" by
Mac Barnett, and Patrick MacDonald.
So, do you want to feel
a skunk, right here?
>> Student: No.
>> Mac Barnett: No, sorry.
The word, the skunk.
You want to feel that?
Put your finger right there.
You want to feel it?
Isn't that cool?
Yeah [comments].
>> Brian Biggs: Cool,
it's like dots, right?
>> Mac Barnett: Yeah,
you want to feel?
There you go.
>> Student: Do not touch the skunk.
>> Brian Biggs: Don't
touch the skunk.
>> Mac Barnett: Does
anybody here want to feel?
>> Brian Biggs: And, don't
upset the skunk either.
>> Mac Barnett: Right
here, put it right there.
>> Brian Biggs: And,
hell don't eat the skunk.
>> Mac Barnett: You want to feel?
Alright, and if anybody didn't get
a chance we'll make sure you pet him
on your way out.
And, we have one more cool
surprise which is that everybody
who came here today is going to get
a copy of Noisy Night, signed by us,
thanks to an Open Book foundation.
>> Brian Biggs: Thank
you Open Book Foundation.
>> Mac Barnett: Give a big round of
applause to an Open Book Foundation
for donating these copies.
>> Brian Biggs: Yeah [applause].
>> Mac Barnett: You all will have
a copy, so just be sure to read it
at night, very loud [laughter],
so everybody will wonder,
what is going on right
next door to me.
Yeah?
>> Student: If I were
you I would not wake
up my baby sister [laughter].
>> Brian Biggs: Well, that's
why I'm glad it's up to you.
How old is your baby sister?
>> Student: She's like
two months old.
>> Brian Biggs: Oh, we're
not going to wake her up.
I'm with you.
>> Mac Barnett: Thank you so
much Tyler Elementary for coming
out this morning, and
thank you to the Library
of Congress for having us.
Bye guys.
>> Brian Biggs: High five.
>> Speaker: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.